[Music]  many people on our staff were very  excited about obama's win last night  except  one of our writers one of our writers  not so happy he's he's actually upset  he's here to talk about it i don't know  why i don't the problem is please  welcome dion cole  hey everybody thanks conan uh so dion uh  you're you're upset that obama won no no  i'm glad obama won what i'm annoyed  about is all morning white people have  been coming up to me congratulating me  as if i did something  just because i'm black  okay well dion i think i think people  mean well  i mean yeah buddy got a little out of  hand conan check this out  [Music]  hey congrats  yeah  hey dion congrats man  [Applause]  is  hey thanks man  what are y'all doing here white people  been trying to high five me all day  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  really nice job dion congratulations  p.m call everybody